[Music]
let's be honest
coronavirus and the climate crisis have
caused massive problems all over the
world
but those aren't the only issues that
we've reported on on fyi
in this programme two of our biggest
investigations
[Music]
first before the coronavirus pandemic
struck
brayden headed to a country where
children are being caught up in the
crossfire of gun violence
[Music]
brazil tourists come here for us
tropical beaches
scenery and of course it's football mad
[Music]
it's not the first time i've traveled 6
000 miles from manchester to rio
[Music]
i am also mad about footing and i came
here a few years back
to see some of the best footy players in
the world in action
me and my sister got to meet some
[Music]
but this time it's no holiday
i'm heading here rios favelas
where the poorest families live
presenting a new show like fyi has
opened my eyes to a side of brazil
i didn't know
a trading drugs and gangs control many
of the favelas
in some areas there are violent gun
battles between the police and gangs
nearly every day
many children and thousands of adults
have been killed
i've heard that there was a police and
gangshu out right outside a school
and one of the students wants to tell us
his story
but this isn't going to be easy i've
been told that it's too dangerous for me
to go into the favela as police have
been going in there
every day for the past two weeks so this
is as close as i'm gonna get
for my own safety
the film crew are going in they have
protection
and they are experts at filming in
dangerous areas
this means ishmael can tell his story
each of these hearts here is a bullet
that was shot into the school
there was about 17 or 18 bullets
he tried to build higher walls to
protect the students
but they haven't finished the job yet
ismael says drug gangs operate right
outside his school
last year he lost his best friend
i was in the playground when the
shooting started and we
started running into the school
including maria
but she didn't make it inside in time to
protect herself
she was a great friend she was taken
away in such a tragic way
i never imagined this would happen in a
school
ismail says in memory of maria and
despite the risks
he's determined to keep going to lessons
and he's not the only one standing up to
the violence
i've gone to another favela to meet
victoria
in an area that hasn't been raided for a
while but just in case
we have security with us and the police
know we are here
i'm here life in the favela is very hard
not just for me but for everyone we're
constantly stressed out
not only because of the criminals but
because of the police
the police make us even more scared
the criminals don't invade our houses
and hurt anyone
criminals don't do that the police say
the purpose of the raids is to make
arrests and they act
on intelligence victoria's home is in an
area of the favela that is raided
constantly by the police and where two
gangs are at war with each other
so can you give us a typical day in a
life of you
a typical day for me i see people doing
drugs on the street
and offering drugs to kids and i see
kids
playing with guns and adults looking on
hello hello
it's my grandmother grandfather
hello my brother hola and my grandfather
hello how are you when she's at her
grandparents
victoria has to look after her little
brother she tells me
her mum works long hours but this hasn't
always been a safe neighborhood to
escape to
randall uh
is victoria was nearly killed by a stray
bullet during a shootout
between the police and the local gang
so they were the bull head
you never know if that would have gone
low it would have gone straight through
the window
what
in 2019 at least 21 children were killed
by stray bullets in rio's favelas
many more were injured
one of those killed was eight-year-old
agatha
her death-leds are protests by families
across the city
demanding better protection it's a
campaign
agatha's mum vanessa and many other
mothers who lost children
planned to keep going i've got a little
eight-year-old sister as well she's
called kara
and although she gets on me nerves a
little bit i love it a bit and i could
not imagine losing her
but when unfortunately your
eight-year-old daughter agreed to passed
away
it led to it sparked a load of different
protests
did that help how did that make you feel
we never expect to be without our kids
especially to lose them in such a tragic
way
the protest is important it's important
to show that my child
had the right to live to study
to survive conversations
[Music]
the brazilian government told fyi they
are determined to take control of the
favelas from the drug gangs
and to do that they must use heavily
armed police to defend themselves from
the armed criminal gangs
victoria told me that when you are poor
and surrounded by crime
some children give up on school and join
the gangs
okay through here but not her and her
mates
they are determined to get to this
classroom every day
some people are stronger than others
here and they can handle the violence
better
we have to be careful because of the
straight bullets but we're determined
we can survive
you can't blame one or the other for the
violence the problem here is a lack of
education
a lack of opportunity to get out of
poverty as well as normal lessons
they focus on dealing with life
surrounded by violence
when i was five or six years old my
father went to prison
everyone here has their problems in my
case it's family problems
you all right i might cry but
i think that makes me strong sometimes i
have wanted to give up trying to make a
life for myself
but science
i'm still fighting
i really don't know how i would cope
with that and you've come
to 14 and you've coped through all of
that so you've done absolutely
amazing but does brazil have the money
to transform the lives of victoria and
her friends
it's been an expensive decade in 2014
brazil spent a whopping two and a half
billion pounds hosting the world cup
two years later another big bill of 11
billion pounds
the construction of rio's olympic
village
as the country hosted the big games
but not everyone was celebrating loads
of people in brazil
are really angry as they feel that the
money spent on the olympics
and the world cup could have been better
spent on the country's poor
today the venue for the games is
deserted
the government say a lot of the venues
are falling apart
because they are too expensive to look
after
all that money just gone to waste
look listen it's silent
you can literally hear the grass moving
it's like a ghost town
just one year after the games ended
these photos were taken of the olympic
pool
empty and full of algae and the stadiums
had been looted and were already falling
apart
the rio olympic village has now been
condemned as unsafe
and officially closed down
it turns out brazil is one of the
richest countries
in the world but you wouldn't think it
that's because most of brazil's money
belongs to a small number of people
the majority of families are on very low
wages
i think this is a lack of respect so
many people in need of food and at home
and instead they spend it on the
olympics it leaves me with
anger in my heart
this is so bad because they spent a lot
of money on these arenas and it could
have been used to buy resources for
schools
we have nothing
the brazilian government says it is
investing millions of pounds in creating
jobs
and has lifted more than 29 million
people out of poverty
charities say much more needs to be done
this amazing football pitch was built by
the charity
street child high above a favela to
protect players from gunfights down
below
[Music]
it may be just a football pitch but for
wesley
it's hope i come to this project
because it's safe here it's the only
place where we are not in the middle of
crossfire
when we try to practice
and today wesley and loads of others get
to escape life in the favelas completely
some local charities take as many kids
as possible down to the beaches of rio
and guess what they play when they're
down at the beach they play
football
[Music]
i thought i would only find hopelessness
during my time in brazil
but through westlake victoria and ismail
i discovered another fight in the
favelas
their fight to escape the poverty and
violence
of good even though my friend got shot
dead going to school
i'm not going to stop my routine it's
hard for me
but i'll not stop going to school we are
not courageous
it's just how we have to live but we
have a choice to make
we can give in to the violence and stay
poor
or stand by our dreams
wow i can't imagine what it must be like
having to cope with the stress of gun
battles going on
directly outside your house thank
goodness we live in a much safer area
than this part of brazil
however there are still some big
problems here affecting our state of
mind
poor mental health is a problem for an
increasing number of us
so ella went online with some of the fyi
crew to go looking for answers
hi guys bye where's ruby
oh hello ella uh i'm not quite sure
we're still waiting for her
hang on then i'll just get connected
oh come on ruby
hey everyone what's the ghost oh there
actually isn't any i just said that to
get you to join
anyway we've been investigating mental
health right so how have you guys been
getting on
yeah well i've actually found out loads
if you click on that i don't get it
shortcut on your desktop
it'll take you to my piece oh yeah i've
got it
here we go enjoy
hello how are you it's such a simple
question
but giving an honest answer can be quite
tricky right
sometimes we feel fed up or worried that
we're not doing as well as our friends
at school
or that no one likes us but is this a
mental health issue
or not here's what i found out how do i
know if i've got a mental health problem
if you're mainly happy and you're able
to cope with stressful things
like this exam paper then you've
probably got good mental health
but if you're nearly always feeling sad
or unhappy
or even worse like that all the time it
might be a warning sign
that you need to get some help maybe
you're not sleeping
because you're constantly worried is it
true
that more children than ever are
suffering from poor mental health
the experts reckon that one in eight of
us are dealing with
some sort of mental health issue at any
one time to help me find out why
he's psychologist emma kenny who helps
loads of kids in her clinic
hi ruby hi so what's going on emma
well first of all you've got to remember
that there are lots of different types
of mental health issues
one of the most common types is anxiety
now everyone gets a little bit anxious
and weird at times
but it becomes an illness when those
feelings go on for months and they
really stop you living a normal life i
think that social media plays a big part
in it
it's quite easy for people to be bullied
online or to be teased for the way that
they look
but you've got to remember your true
friends will
always accept you exactly as you are
while ruby good work we seek to serve
well that stuff that emma said about
social media making you worry about your
appearance kind of struck a chord
do you guys ever worry about that i mean
yeah
i've been bullied quite a lot especially
in like primary and first year of
secondary school
because the way i look i think people
try to use people's insecurities
to target them yeah and social media
can kind of make things worse because
you see all of these people and then you
get into your head that
if you don't have a certain type of body
people won't like you or something
and even with me people have told me in
the past oh tia why are you so skinny
people might think oh being skinny is a
good thing but if you're hearing it
constantly can actually
like you can take it to heart and it can
be hurtful well i'm
lucky enough i've never really worried
about that no one's ever said anything
like that to me
but i was actually seen recently that
a footballer called luke chadwick who
used to play for manchester united
said people sent him not nice messages
because of the way he
his appearances it hurt his feelings and
really made him feel
mentally unstable but he also said how
important it is to talk to people
because talking reduces half of the
problem
yeah well guys i want to meet someone
else
who was teased and bullied because of
the way he looked his name's nick
and he lives in western superman hi nick
hey braden how are you such a pleasure
to be here today
i know the pleasure's all arsenic but if
you don't mind could you please tell us
what happened when you were born
well when i was young like when i was
born um i was born with this
melanocytic newbie which was like a mole
that covered
three quarters of my face and it could
have been cancer
so my parents decided to remove it when
it was removed after
a lot of operations it left scarring on
my face
and what kind of impact did that have on
you
[Music]
well when i started school
um primary school mainly people started
to pick on me and started to call me
name
started to be physically abusive towards
me i then thought like
is there something wrong with me and
then i did feel
a lot of depression well nick i actually
know that you now go into schools and
give speeches about your experiences
in fact i've got a clip that i'd like to
share with you now let me just get it up
uh here we go my vision has been for all
individuals in society to embrace
each other's differences for the world
to be a better place
[Applause]
well nick it is amazing to see that you
do that
and it's also really inspirational but
how did you overcome
the hurtful things that people said to
you well
we all have our different methods but my
method was through
art personally i did not have a voice
when i was younger due to all of the
harsh things that were said or done to
me
so art was really my way of expressing
feeling well nick thank you very much
for talking to us it's been wonderful
speaking to you
and it's great to know that you're
turning all the negatives into positives
thank you hey guys i've just spotted
that bella ramsay is one of the
ambassadors for young minds one of the
charities that works on this kind of
thing
really you mean the actress from the
worst witch
yeah i mean i could track her down
should i give it a try
yeah i bet you can britain all right all
right then
give me two minutes
[Music]
hey have you guys heard of junior fruit
no who were they
well he was bullied just like nick was
but not because of the way he looks but
just because he was into dancing
and everyone told him that boys
shouldn't be dancers isn't that awful
that's so unfair some of the best
answers i know boys
yeah you're right well i just sent you a
video click on it when it's finished
downloading and you'll see what happens
to him
hi i'm junior and i'm a street dancer
from leeds
i've been dancing since i was three
years old i love to dance
because i can switch my feelings through
dance and i can feel free
and happy all through primary school i
was playful of my dancing
it got so bad after move schools and
move house
but i kept on dancing
i shoved the bullets that i wasn't
afraid to dance just because i was a boy
throughout my anti-bullying campaign
hashtag boy skin dance
i have raised over three hundred
thousand pounds and i've won lots of
accolades
such as the british citizen award the
teen hero award
the diana award and it didn't stop there
through my dancing i have been back up
dancer with justin bieber
and a little mix
[Applause]
i want to say if you want to dance
always go for it and believe in yourself
pretty amazing don't you think yeah it
was and it's great
that those celebrities wanted to help
him and give him so many opportunities
and guys i've arranged for him to join
our chat
hi junior great to have you here could
you tell us a bit about how the bullying
affected your mental health
it was really really bad actually
because i felt really isolating and
quite upset and like kept self to myself
but i told someone and then i got
through it and it really helped me
how do you suggest people who don't
necessarily have support from
celebrities
get over the bullying that they're
facing um
i always tell someone a parent or a
teacher i don't need close to
thanks for joining us junior so i guess
what we've learned from that
is that you can beat the bullies it just
takes guts to talk to people about it
thank you
i'm back oh hi brayden did you manage to
get hold of bella ramsay
yeah of course i did she'll be joining
us really soon
yeah that was quick brodin
hey everyone how are you brady told me
you were talking about mental health
yeah we are it's amazing that you've
joined us
why do you think poor mental health has
become such a big issue with our
generation
um i think there's so much pressure
nowadays from like this on social media
and also friends
and school it just seems to be like a
lot of pressure placed on young people
and it can all get overwhelming and i
know it's affected you in the past are
you able to
talk to us about it now yeah of course
so
i had an eating disorder for two years
which kind of stemmed from being away
from home without my mum for a period of
time when i was filming
um and with that came uh anxiety
i am now fully recovered from the eating
disorder i still get anxious every so
often but um
i'm a lot better than i was and yeah
it's just
that's kind of what i've gone through
but i'm still always working on it
how did you get yourself mentally strong
again
my faith really helped and i just kind
of remind myself now that i can
i have a choice of how i respond i can't
control what's going on but i can
control how i respond to it
and that's kind of helped me a lot thank
you so much for joining us bella
i've actually got a few ideas of my own
of how to say mentally healthy as well
click on that i don't get it shortcut on
your desktop and it'll take you to the
rest of my report
okay here we go here's the good news
i found out there's lots of small things
you can do that make a big difference to
your mental health
like running swimming or playing
football for example
exercise is not just good for your body
it's also good for your mind
but if the idea of getting spotty fills
you up with horror
then why not try a different hobby like
learning to play an instrument
dancing or even painting
not bad i need to take a snap of this
hang on here's another bit of advice
i know we all love our gadgets me
included but we don't have to use them
all the time
sometimes it's good to just talk to your
friends face to face instead of
messaging them and sending them pictures
yeah i know you're right but it's just
one picture
all right but just one but promise me
take lots of screen breaks it'll really
help you to stay mentally healthy
okay that's a deal
oh nice picture ruby hey tia weren't you
gonna try and sort out some more people
for us to talk to about this
yep i've done it so you've just had
emma's advice about limiting our screen
time
but 15 year old rusiri from wells has
completely given up his smartphone to
help his mental health
hi every suru hi and i've also got
rachel from lincolnshire who's 12
who's been doing loads of different
activities to help her overcome anxiety
and panic attacks
hi rachel hello hello
so rusyru you've got to be like the only
15 year old in the country who
doesn't have a smartphone why did you
give it up
yeah so um i just found that my phone
was causing me distractions from my work
um i guess it's also a lot more relaxing
without having the phone to check all
the time or notifications bombarding you
so your school was started phone free
friday haven't they so how's that going
down with your friends
i would say as a whole that the reaction
to it has been very good
i mean overall i think it has had a
massively positive effect on us
and rachel i know that you've had mental
health issues in the past can you tell
us a bit about
what your struggles were so i have
anxiety and regular panic attacks
and um i think this all started in
english when i was about
seven or eight where um i was sick in
front of the entire class
and that's a really difficult thing to
go through so how did you get yourself
mentally strong again
well i have a huge passion for drama and
just being able
to be someone or not for a short while
really kind of
makes me feel better about myself but
it's obviously not easy having anxiety
with things that are going on at the
moment with the coronavirus
i think most of us have probably worried
about it at some point
yeah i know i definitely have been
especially at the start i was definitely
worried about my friends and
family um but as time goes on you kind
of
you get used to it and you kind of know
that it's going to be all right
well thank you both for speaking to us
so honestly it's been a pleasure having
you here
thank you for having us guys you're not
gonna believe it but we're gonna have to
wrap this up we're out of time
oh that's a shame it's gone so quickly
yeah i think it's been really helpful
talking about stuff like this because
it's good to not get embarrassed or
anything and it's worth just saying
if you want to talk to anyone about
mental health issues
there's a whole list of charities and
organizations on our website
there's not news fyi oh yeah i can see
them now
we've really got to go now but thank you
for watching and we'll see you next time
bye bye and for more fyi investigates
check out our website first.news fyi
where we're looking at the battle to
save endangered wildlife
and the story of how coronavirus spread
all over the world
[Music]
bye